Koristi ispravna imena za ljude,
knjige, filozofske škole itd.
radili i gde smo se, jel da, zaustavili.
Sada idemo dalje.
Dakle, kada je reč po ljudima, preduđemo
sa ljudima da vidimo koji to ljudi
rade, šta rade, kako rade, kakav je njihov
odnos prema državi kao organizaciji.
Dakle, državu kao organizaciju
ne čine svi građani, ne čini svoj
taj državni aparat čine
samo neke ljudi. Ti ljudi
koji čine taj državni aparat,
oni se nazivaju državni službenici.
Znači, to su ljudi
koji rade u idei za račun države.
E sad,
tim državnim službenim licima se
daje u okređenom poslu.
Dakle,
imate zaprijeđene državne službene priče,
daš im da radi neki posao
i taj posao predstavlja njegovu radu.
Budim na to
da vam što jednostavnije objasnim,
ne da se držim tih definicija iz učbenika,
nego najprostije je moguće
da vam objasnim.
Dakle, uzmeš neki posao, daš ga jednom
državom službeno viši, kažeš evo ti,
napravo daš da radi to,
to je tvoja nadležnost, bukvalno tako.
E sada, postoje dve vrste nadležnosti,
u principu i ova treća nekako funkcionalno
te uopšte nije zakonska kategorija,
ali se često spominje,
pa ću vam nju objasniti,
i prisutna je naravno
u radu državnih rodana,
Ali nije zakonska kategorija.
Da krenemo od stvari, dakle,
ako uzmete recimo jednog sudiva
koji je državu službe novice
i jednog narodnog poslanika
koji je državu službe novice,
da li oni radi isti?